Fastuoso, desmesurado, colosal. Dubái parece siempre aspirar a llevar a cabo
los proyectos más grandes, más lujosos
y más excéntricos del mundo. En este
pequeño territorio, perteneciente a los
Emiratos Árabes Unidos, y situado en un
estratégico enclave em la desembocadura del
Golfo Pérsico, podemos encontrar el
edificio más alto, el hotel más lujoso e
incluso el aeropuerto internacional
más grande del mundo. El proceso de
crecimiento de Dubái está siendo uno
los más veloces de toda la historia del ser
humano y en poco más de 20 años ha
pasado de ser un remoto enclave en el desierto a convertirse en una de las
grandes capitales del mundo.
En este periodo ha logrado multiplicar
por cuatro su población, por nueve  el número
de visitantes y por ocho otro el tamaño de su
economía, pero ¿cómo ha sido todo esto
posible? ¿Se debe todo al petróleo? Hoy en
Visual Politik
hablamos de Dubái.
Dubái es ya la cuarta urbe con más visitantes
internacionales del mundo, superando a
epicentros del turismo y el comercio
global como Nueva York, Hong Kong o
Singapur.
Dubái es un estado dentro de los
Emiratos Árabes unidos, podríamos
calificar su gobierno como una teocracia
islámica que restringe buena parte de
las libertades civiles.
Sin embargo, si lo comparamos con sus
países vecinos, Dubái es sin duda el
lugar más aperturista de la zona,
por ejemplo las mujeres pueden ir por la
calle sin velo. Nadie se llama
a engaño Dubnái no aspira a ser el lugar más
libre la tierra, pero sí el más rico.
Las muestras de opulencia son tan
evidentes que no es extraño ver a la
policía del emirato patrullando las
calles a bordo de Ferraris o Lamborghinis
¿en qué otro lugar podemos encontrar
algo así? Hay quien puede pensar que todo el proceso
se debe al oro negro, que Dubái no es más
que un sueño de jeques financiado con
petrodólares.
Sin embargo, aunque la influencia del
petróleo es innegable y ha sido un gran
aliado
la verdadera clave para su desarrollo ha
sido su apuesta por el libre comercio.
A finales de los años 50 se
descubrieron grandes pozos de petróleo
en las inmediaciones de Abu Dhabi, la
capital de Emiratos. La riqueza
petrolífera era tal que hoy se estima que
las reservas probadas de Emiratos son
mayores incluso que la de toda Rusia.
Sin embargo, el caso particular de Dubái
era un tanto distinto "dependíamos
de los recursos energéticos fósiles,
gas y generación de energía." Y, aunque
agraciado con la fortuna del oro negro,
sus autoridades pronto se dieron cuenta
que sus reservas eran más bien
pequeñas y desde luego mucho más
limitadas que la de sus vecinos.
De hecho, y frente a lo que pudiéramos
pensar, el petróleo apenas supone hoy
poco más de un euro de cada cien que
genera la economía dubaití, pero ¿qué hizo
dubai para lograr semejante desarrollo y
conseguir un nivel de vida mayor incluso
que el de sus vecinos ricos en petróleo?
Pues fundamentalmente apostar por atraer
multinacionales y profesionales de
todo el mundo.
Para ello, en primer lugar Dubái apostó
por una política de bajos impuestos,
sobre todo si lo comparamos con los
parámetros a los que estamos
acostumbrados en Europa. En Dubái el
impuesto sobre beneficios es
prácticamente inexistente, no hay
impuesto sobre la renta y hasta ahora
tampoco había iva. Y, sí, es verdad,
próximamente se va introducir un
impuesto equivalente a lo que en España
entendemos cómo IVA pero el tipo que se
va a fijar estará en torno al 4% ¡que
lejos del 21 verdad que nos afecta a
nosotros!
Y, por supuesto, en Dubái, como podéis
imaginar tampoco hay  impuesto sobre los
hidrocarburos,
la gasolina está libre de fiscalidad. "Queremos que la próxima
generación sea capaz de celebrar el
último barril de petróleo, no vamos a
depender del curdo." En segundo
lugar
Dubái recurrió un instrumento conocido
como Zonas Francas, si bien en este
caso un tanto diferentes a las que
podemos encontrar en otros lugares, en
Dubái estos espacios, además de tener
beneficios fiscales también cuentan con
sus propias leyes, enfocadas siempre a
promover la actividad empresarial.Algo que es trascendental
en esta parte del mundo. Gracias a tener
normas específicas, los empresarios
pueden escapar a la regided de los
sistemas legales
inspirados en la sharía, de aplicación,
por supuesto, en el resto del Emirato.
Un buen ejemplo de este modelo es el conocido
como Centro Financiero Internacional de
Dubái, que es casi un estado dentro de
otro estado. El Centro Financiero cuenta
con su propio sistema judicial, de
inspiración anglosajona y que está
presidido por un juez británico; su
propia lengua oficial que no es el
árabe sino el inglés; he incluso ha
sustituido el dirham emiratí por el
dólar americano como moneda vinculante.
De esta forma, una entidad financiera
puede hacer negocios como si estuviese
en Manhattan, pero beneficiándose de las
ventajas fiscales de Dubái. Así, no
resulta extraño que esta zona haya
sido capaz de atraer a la mayoría de
los 25 bancos más grande del mundo.
Junto a las zonas francas y la política
de impuestos bajos, el Emirato también
apostó por la libertad migratoria y hoy
el 96 por ciento de sus habitantes ha
nacido en el extranjero. Y también
apostó por promover la inversión
extranjera,
de hecho en el año 2002 las autoridades
del Emirato presentaron un decreto por el
cual cualquier extranjero podía
realizar inversiones inmobiliarias,
algo realmente infrecuente en los países árabes. Comenzó entonces una época dorada en
la que se sucedieron grandes proyectos
fastuosos, cientos de rascacielos,
imponente centros comerciales, grandes
resorts e incluso islas artificiales.
De hecho, en este período, Dubái ha
tenido un desarrollo inmobiliario sólo
comparable al de Shanghái, ciudad con 13
veces más habitantes y donde antes
había un rascacielos hoy hay más de
700. El último gran proyecto sobre la
mesa, es "The Mall Of The World", un gigantesco
espacio de más de cuatro con cinco
millones de metros cuadrados, llamado a
convertirse en el mayor centro comercial
del mundo, y que albergará incluso su
propio distrito cultural con decenas de
teatros y cines, cien  hoteles y el mayor
parque temático cubierto del mundo. El
proyecto ha sido presentado como la
primera ciudad con temperatura
controlada del planeta.
Todas estas políticas han hecho de
Dubái un lugar donde es fácil hacer
negocios y lo han convertido no sólo en
una potencia comercial, turística y
financiera, sino también en una potencia
logística e industrial. Hoy Dubái
es ya la tercera mayor fuerza re-exportadora de
todo el mundo y su producción
industrial supera los 50.000 millones de
dólares cada año.
Mientras sus vecinos observan inquietos
como el precio del petróleo se desploma
y hay analistas internacionales que
cuestionan incluso la solvencia de muchos
de estos países, como es el caso de Arabia  Saudita, el gobierno de Dubái se muestra
confiado, he incluso su presupuesto para
2016 lo ha incrementado en un 12 por
ciento. "Tenemos que aprovecharnos de la
crisis, presenta oportunidades para
nosotros." Es verdad, desde una óptica
estrictamente política
existen muchos elementos reprobables, en
materia religiosa, social y de derechos
humanos.
Desde luego no queremos obviar esta
realidad pero no podemos dejar de
prestar atención a los logros que ha cosechado
estado este lugar, y precisamente esto es
lo que genera la pregunta esencial ¿es
posible compatibilizar ausencia de
derechos civiles con crecimiento
sostenible? La historia y la evidencia
empírica parecen demostrar que no, pero
en un mundo cada vez más presionado por
impuestos muy altos y regulaciones de
todo tipo, sus autoridades parecen
empeñadas en demostrar que esta vez sí
es posible. De momento su apuesta por el
libre comercio y la inversión y sus
políticas encaminadas a reforzar la
seguridad jurídica, la facilidad para
hacer negocios y mantener los impuestos
bajos, han tenido un éxito superlativo.
Si algo nos muestra Dubái es que el
desarrollo se fundamenta en la actividad
económica y las relaciones comerciales
y no en el proteccionismo y las
políticas de subvenciones. Muchos
gobernantes deberían prestar atención
a los éxitos de este oasis en el
desierto.